thank you for coming to my talk
my name is bagif and this hour we'll be
talking about open Telemetry tracing and
what does it mean for net Developers
so I work for Norwegian company miles
last few years actually last probably
seven or six years I've been working
mostly with F-sharp but like any.net
developer I I've gone my c-sharp story
and uh all examples here will be in
c-sharp so if it's open Telemetry it's a
platform agnostic it's language agnostic
you don't really need to think about
which language you choose but of course
it's easier if I present examples in C
sharp who who is familiar with c-sharp
the honest yeah everyone so it should be
problem but again things uh except for
the demos which we've been C sharp the
rest is actually platform agnostic this
is also what is good about open
telemetry
so before we uh start going deeper let's
start with the beginning the very
beginning so in the beginning uh there
were services and there were UI
and they were not observable like
Services ever completely without
observability of a void and darkness was
upon the face of the UI
so and that of course was a was a
problem so
God said said let there be locked
if you are old enough you may recognize
the face of the gentleman it's a
vocalist of the band AC DC and these
pictures are taken from the official
video Let There be Rock
so that song was about rock and roll but
we
tweak it uh twist it around open
Telemetry so there are lots of course
logs is the first thing you do to make
things uh observable
uh that still was not sufficient so the
God said let there be traces
and there were traces and the world
became way better with that
that still wasn't sufficient and the God
said let there be metrics
and there were metrics
let there be open Telemetry God said
after that and at that point
you uh probably the three first
statements were uh easy okay I I don't
need to convince you that you need uh
metrics logging traces but okay why open
Telemetry we all have logs where you've
been using Serie log or log phonet or
anything like that with interfaces you
could easily switch log things uh
so is it just a new buzzword what is it
for for us
so this is actually the purpose of this
talk try to convince you that
there is something which we can actually
adopt it's worth adopting uh which uh
can give us uh Great Value in what we're
doing especially if we dealing with
distributed Services If part of our
services uh developed by different teams
or maybe during using different
platforms
so uh in modern Services we have
observability in forms of logs I guess
everyone does logs who does logs in one
of the different ways yeah so almost
everyone who does traces we can TR you
can trace track down the execution of
your application
it's still uh maybe half but less than
uh logs who is capable of doing
distributed traces
impressive but of course fewer hands and
who needs metrics and who does metrics
yeah it's similar to traces Maybe
so this is a logging I don't need to
explain much this is from elasticsearch
from from kiban this is how
logs and of course you just
write
describe the snapshot of your service or
application execution and the problem
with with logs that it may take you
quite a lot of time to inspect inspect
and search for and build the context out
of individual logs because each row is
just an individual
snapshot of what happened at that moment
of time
in that service or maybe in many
services if there are several different
services that log in here so tracing in
that respect is
is better if you need to track down the
sequence of events you actually you have
a context here so you don't really need
to log much of context related
information because it for you it will
happen some somebody some back end will
uh have it for you big here it's a
tracing user Jagger jagu UI it's it's a
browser but this is not distributed
Tracer this is just uh uh one
application so it becomes more
interesting when you have distributed
tracing here you see there are
two applications that uh
contribute to tracing there is web app
and then there is queue consumer so the
web web app publishes uh rabbit mq
message and this uh Q consumer reads a
message from rabbitmq so this is uh this
becoming interesting and I will actually
look at how to uh how you can enrich
your protocol with uh support for open
Telemetry and we will use rabbitmq as
example
uh of course you have metrics this is uh
grafana
one of them most popular dashboards for
both logging and metrics and traces
so open Telemetry uh for observability I
was trying to find something that is
easy to unexplain to a back-end
developer and of course we all work with
uh databases and then okay what what can
uh be
uh really really to grasp for that back
back and develop I was thinking about
enter framework but then no it's it's a
bad analogy because anti-framework is is
not multi-platform well basically also
it's not multi-language it's all built
around a c-sharp so then I thought that
maybe bad analogy also good example
because this is uh you will remember
that okay open Telemetry actually uh has
is multi-platform and multi-language so
it's completely agnostic but if you if
you look at uh the history of uh
uh developing various common standards
for database connectivity actually
Microsoft uh we're talking about like
dotnet so we are in the context of
Microsoft products they've been doing it
all the time like 30 years ago it came
odbc then oledb with straight like
strange acronym object link and the
bending for databases like adoadio.net
and then enter framework so this has
always been demand for doing common uh
uh standard for that so you don't need
to think about details of Oracle
database driver about SQL server and the
same goes for open Telemetry so you uh
until open to them they came like with
logging we actually we got this
flexibility with logging interfaces but
when it comes to traces
and metrics especially we were locked
much more to specific back-ends to
specific dashboards and uh always it
resulted that different teams made their
own choices and it was hard to cooperate
so what open to empty provides it's uh
first of all it's a single vendor
agnostic instrumentation Library per
language
so uh you have a language of your choice
whether it be c-sharp F sharp rust Java
and then you have a library
which and those libraries they produce
something that can uh cooperate uh no
matter what what is uh your project
platform
it's automatic and all manual
instrumentation that's also very
important point we will have a look at
it later
with like example of manual
instrumentation is logging when you need
to write a log statement for anything
that happens open cylinder gives you a
possibility to turn on and off
instrumentation for various protocols
like instrument all HTTP calls and then
you have it both on client and server
side instrument all SQL Server calls and
then you can see the actual SQL
statements which are generated or MySQL
if you if you want to if there is a
protocol that is not supported by
openterm you can write something on your
own
a single vendor neutral Telemetry
collector binary so uh Telemetry
collects also it by open Telemetry you
don't need to write anything for that
and it provides collection of
telemetrical data you only need when the
specific Telemetry exporters so whether
you choose elastic application inside
honeycomb then of course you need
something render specific but of course
the
Telemetry providers they they give you
they give you these exporters
uh data tell them to data sent to
multiple destinations in parallel which
means that you don't need to sacrifice
your performance if you want to send it
to different backends
and data collection is vendor agnostic
uh
finally which is a very important
context propagation for disabled
scenarios is that if you have multiple
services and they talk to each other
then there is a
uh
specification how uh context can be
propagated from uh one service to
another and it it's done it's in very
efficient way basically as we will see
in uh example with rabbit mq it's just
to enrich your communication your
payload with couple of headers you need
to provide the correlation ID or like
Trace ID or you need to provide parent
ID so it will be it should be possible
to uh find out who is a parent of of
that Trace
open Telemetry also is a good case for
application performance monitoring if
you look at uh
um services like uh uh elasticsearch
like honeycomb applications like they
all uh offer you some uh application
performance monitoring uh services so
you can uh collect information about how
your applications perform without need
to build your own custom dashboards and
those data like more and more providers
of such Services they use open Telemetry
to build this information and this APM
can be used to validate compliance with
uh service level objectives
here NDC one responsive NDC is Honeycomb
and uh you can if you want register free
account at honeycomb
which gives you some
number of metrics you can you can
collect every every day so it's it's
enough to to try it with relatively
complex examples and then they support
setting service level objectives so you
can specify that you want that
percentage of calls to be finished with
it that uh time and then you will get a
report about whether this service Labs
objectives are met or not and all this
telemetic data collected using open
telemetry
yeah this is what uh more and more
vendors implement
so this example
uh application performance monitoring
dashboard from elastic elastic APM you
see this is you get from elastic of
course it's opinionated so it's not
dashboard that you have built yourself
but uh probably you're busy with other
things
solving domain problems uh you you can
more efficiently use your time then
build custom dashboards you uh you you
can get pretty Advanced dashboards from
different providers
so why did I personally start looking at
open Telemetry and that also explains
why I've chosen open Telemetry tracing
for this talk because we know that open
telems it's not just tracing it's
tracing it's metrics and logging well
first of all uh logging is uh I mean
probably if all open terms would be just
about a new standard for logging it it
would be really hard to sell because
logging is like explored and
generalized in yeah in pretty good way
so uh
also if you can compare tracing and
metrics uh implementation of open
Telemetry in with traces it has gone
much further than this metrics both are
still not like RCM version one but uh uh
open Telemetry and so you can see you
can still uh hit some uh
um breaking changes but uh with uh with
traces tracing you I mean we've been
using it production for for quite some
time
and of course tracing is something
especially distributed traces that we
found uh really interesting in um in our
organization we really need that to
trace across the whole organization our
services so I was tired of investigating
zillions of logs and so logging was
primary way of us to expose
observability of our services and
whenever a problem happened then I had
we had to search logs basically search
trying to find some using some IDs and
that's not really efficient way of doing
that also we had to search through
different dashboards because we have uh
our organization is quite liberal like
different teams can choose their own
dashboards they can choose their
backends to a certain extent so uh and
uh okay you have these services using
that dashboard this is using that
dashboard and then you have to actually
search through multiple uh dashboard to
find out what what's what went wrong and
that that's of that's not way to
implement that
um and uh a good trace is worth a
thousand logs
uh also all services should participate
in distributed tracing that's the whole
point of uh using open Telemetry for
tracing
and services should be capable of
collating trade data automatically no no
longer this log statements uh entering
SQL call SQL call is finished without
that result or HTTP client returned this
uh everyone you you don't need that you
you should get it all automatically
back-ends can be changed without
revising codes that's also quite
important point so you use open
Telemetry you you can switch uh backends
and you don't need to change your code
just change your configuration
articles used by APM servers as I
mentioned before that it's quite
important for application performance
monitoring
so open Telemetry works with signals and
there are four main signals it's a logs
traces metrics and baggage baggage it's
a
metadata we should attach uh to other
signals so there is some confusion about
terminology
between dotnet and open telemt
because.net actually has had for a long
time for a couple of decades uh
something similar to what open to empty
works with so what is called Tracer in
open Telemetry it's activity source
in.net
what is a span or telemetries panel open
Telemetry is activity
and what is context span context is
activity context so it's it's easy sort
of to to memorize but you just have to
deal with that so when you work with
open Telemetry outside.net you will see
like span context and when you
enter.net in your application you'll be
activity context just remember that
uh there is also
as I mentioned uh what is really
interesting uh with uh distributed
tracing has to have automatic spine
creation then you can get uh
automatically injected new segments of
your distributed transactions uh
depending on what you uh enable so you
start activity somewhere for example
when you receive message from service
bus or rabbitmq you start a root
activity and then segments will be
created for you and you can do it for
configure for HTTP clients requests for
incoming asp.net service calls grpc
calls SQL calls like you name it write
your own
uh messaging Frameworks can be about
tricky with automatics pancreation like
we in our organization we have two
messaging Frameworks and service bus and
akka.net aqua.net has a commercial
Library it's called Phobos
which can be used to automatically
create a telemet response uh what we
found with both of them is that because
of the nature of message processing
especially with uh if if it's
actor-based system uh it can uh you can
end up with quite a lot of segments uh
because typically with actors you have
like a single responsibility actors are
typically very very small and they'll
just work each active workshops with one
thing uh receive message did some works
and uh further so it's it's uh like you
can it's similar to like uh having a
great telemetic data for for a class so
you can end up with a quite huge number
of segments uh for your distributed
calls which which is hard if interested
scenario if you have multiple services
from the whole organization
participating in distributed transaction
and then suddenly you have like 1500
segments from your uh tiny service so uh
we work together with ARCA team and they
actually uh made changes uh oh additions
to today Focus Library which supports
now two uh modes of creating spans like
you can have full control of that you
can say okay this is my business
transaction I I create spans here or you
can let uh a library does it then it's
still interesting uh for example to
solve some performance cases uh
so so how do you start with open
telemetry.net
uh of course you with.net when you start
with new technology it always you start
with adding nuget package so there is a
go to new.org and then find open
Telemetry so from them you will find
open remedy nuget package
so
that's basic for two ads open to them to
support for your application of course
it will give you no output unless you
include some exporters so add some more
packages if you want to see all traces
in your console add open Telemetry
exporter console add promatos if you
want to use parameters as backend and
and so on
then in addition if you want automatic
open Telemetry data creation for various
protocols you should also add packages
for those
instrumentation HTTP open Trend
Transportation SQL client so those are
instrumentation types of operator
limited packages
can then access
actually the same way like you you
bootstrap typical asp.net or service
Windows service application
so when do you search for open telemetry
you don't find
something you want to have start at open
telemetry.io
uh so uh the
platform acoustic entrance to open
Telemetry you see here both Java and
goend.net and JavaScript and then
from that there you can go to
open telemetry.net project and then you
will see what is available and you will
see that there are some basic things
available like in-memory Jagger
aspect.net core HTTP listener and zip
canons and so on
grpc SQL server and then there is a huge
list of open telemetric collector
contributions
those contributed by open source
Developers so most likely you you will
find something for you if if you work
with something esoteric or specific you
can probably write your own we will have
an example it's not really hard to add
your own support for open Telemetry for
for certain protocols so check uh GitHub
of course GitHub is also a great place
to check the things check vendors
repository uh honeycomb they uh
have open open open source package for
um open Telemetry in the GitHub uh
account they also publish it on uh look
at datadog excellent support for open
telemundry though expensive
they have something there like MySQL for
example
there are several MySQL providers for
drivers4.net if you use MySQL connector
that comes with support for open
telemetry and right here on
so vendors who support open celebrity
it's a I made this list a couple of
months ago and then I'm I'm sure it's uh
it's much longer well it's actually it's
not the whole list it's just a few that
probably you will recognize something
like Azure lws elastic and so on and the
the list is uh at the time when I looked
at that it was probably like three times
as large now it's even larger uh just
for uh your information we started uh
with
using elasticsearch we were not
completely happy with the way it uh
presents the distributed transactions uh
also we find it was not a very like
stable for complex scenarios uh and
took some time actually to present uh
distributed traces for uh where multiple
Services were involved application sites
works uh well cost it can be quite
expensive uh so we consider currently
grafana temp because then you can
build it on the top of your own storage
which potentially might
give you lower costs and grafana is a
great dashboard
so uh now let's
have a look at how can you can
instrument dotnet application with open
telemetry
so what we're going to do we will look
at bootstrapping how you bootstrap
application how you can add exporters
instrumentation
telemeter sources
then we will have a look at how we
collect traces in a single application
just small console application
then we go from single application to
distributed scenario where multiple
applications are involved uh and then we
will look at more complex scenario how
you can actually have your own custom
Trace propagation and we will use a
rabbitmq which is a popular queuing
Library who is using or familiar with
opt-inq
ah more than half uh so that probably
should give you confidence uh in if you
have worked with something that don't
have support for open to lived out of
the box you will see how easy it is to
uh to add it
okay so with that
I'm going to
to Rider
what about phones is it sufficient to
I don't want to make it very large
because then we will see but should I
make it a bit larger or is it okay
okay
so what we will be using here
um
so this is
okay let me see
so we have a
maybe just make a final duck pause yeah
so this is Docker dropping voice file
with I'm using Docker here so we have
MySQL we have SQL Server we have Robert
mq so it's it's all just so we can run
everything on um on my uh Mac and we'll
be using uh Jagger
so this is jagu UI
yeah so I can find some traces yeah now
it's empty because I tested it I tried
it before when I was rehearsing this
talk this morning and uh it shows me by
default for the last hour or something
so now it's empty uh so we will start
first with uh
very small console application
where
what it will be doing uh there is a list
of words
quick brown folks jumped over the lazy
dog and then it will create
recursively to make it more interesting
so we have like nested traces uh it's a
start a start activity so we always need
to start activity
uh like as a root activity
which will start distributed Trace so it
will uh recursively
start activities for for each new world
and then it said it will set tags count
and word then if it will delay
some milliseconds so we'll see like the
activity they will have some lengths and
it will continue
and I think we will run it
10 times yeah it will run 10 times so
let's try that
uh uh okay and there is a there is not
much of
yeah there is a very little
configuration here uh we we add SDK
create Trace provider Builder this week
we have from uh open Telemetry we have
to add source
so we have to enable what sources uh uh
write to open Telemetry so we can switch
them on and off uh then there is a yeah
set resource Builder it's a
so I will understand that it's from
Services it should it's like also like
another way of saying adding a source
then uh you have a jagger exporter so we
want to export to to Jagger and we want
also to export to console so all we that
we're going to reproduce we will see on
the console also will be sent to jug
export also uh
uh if you have a honeycomb account you
can also use it use it I will not use
honeycomb in this demo but the output is
quite similar to uh what we will see in
Jagger
so let's run this
application console up run
yeah so it displays something
yeah and you will see we have it
something uh on the console
activity ID duration so on but of course
there is not much to see it's better to
search
console
yeah we have 10 traces and you see that
each Trace has eight spans
so if we open this spans
this is a simple transaction oh no this
is just Trace transaction not
distributed yet
uh so if you look at uh
people
tags here and and it has count two word
Forks so we enriched this Trace segment
with some additional information and
because we made it uh recursively then
now we have this Trace which consists of
uh
eight segments or eight uh telemet
response if it use open Telemetry
language or activity or uh what is
called activity span of uh
for
dotnet so uh
but everything we did manually so it's
not distributed it's all created
manually instead of you have it as a
proof of concept that it kind of works
but we want something which is more
interesting
so next uh step we go to web app
so we have a
program and then the same thing that we
want to get this
sentence about quick lazy fox but from
the database so you see here we we want
also show now some
uh automatic uh spam creation so we have
uh
Outsource uh message Publishers from
message queuing uh we have uh aspect.net
construmentation we have SQL client
instrumentation different vendors may
have different Syntax for specifying how
to add their uh
instrumentation of their Source like for
MySQL unit specified adsource MySQL
connector while for SQL Server it's at
SQL Cloud instrumentation so it's a
there is no uh sort of standard
agreement about how they do it most of
them have some extensions message so you
can have some add XXX instrumentation
but not all of them so we will not be
using MySQL I think we'll be using just
uh SQL client and of course our export
is still Jagger uh yeah honeycomb
you may have and also console exporter
so uh what application does it uh we
have a
yeah here we have a choice of backend
but basically it's a it's a website
using a minimal API
so you have slash reset you start from
from the first word and then uh
then you when you uh Slash word if you
write then it will uh increment word
index and then get things from the
database
so let's try to
run it
okay stop and build stop and run
okay okay
we are on reset and then if you try now
word
quick
brown fox and so on yeah so
so let's see how our Jagger will look
now
so now we have a
Hotel web app find traces
yeah actually I really have it
distributed because uh when I was
rehearsing uh talk I started open
telemediq consumer so what this
application does also when this web
service when it gets a word from the
database it also sends it to rabbitmq
database so we we have it here
uh
so if I if I stop my Q consumer let me
see where is that
Q consumer let me stop it
because I want it for
for a different demo and then we
we try
again
over the
lazy
then I go to Jager and then web app find
traces yeah you see the three
uh last traces are not distributed
because Q consumer wasn't running
so but we have now automatic creation of
spans because uh in the application code
we basically just set up our exporter
set up what extra instrumentation we
want to send to open uh to open
Telemetry and that's it and then what we
did we enabled uh asp.net core
uh instrumentation will enable SQL
client instrumentation so if you look
here
uh this is slash word so we get it from
our web app and then you see that the
HTTP method get so all this is coming
automatically collected for us by open
Telemetry without us doing anything we
just enabled it and if you look at
um I think this one is
um or maybe before that
yeah this is uh this comes from SQL uh
server instrumentation which we enabled
you see uh here is the SQL statement
that that is executed so also this is
collected for us by open Telemetry uh
what they found is that it's good for
um
like in initial stage to collect uh
everything uh then uh typically you you
don't want uh that level of
instrumentation like of course you you
only need a SQL statements for you to be
collected if you're dealing with some
problem with uh with circle database but
uh for them purposes now and also as a
as a proof of how easy you can get
instrumentation on on each level you
need that
uh works pretty well so but it's not
distributed yet
so to make it distributed Let's uh
because now we what we were doing we
were manually sending through browser
some requests so now we have web app
client so let's run it which will run
several times
for us Jagger UI
web app find traces
yeah now we see there is distributed
traces here it's a web client and web
app
so if I open the trace
I have
here my web client with
some additional data here for webclite I
enabled automatic HTTP client
instrumentation so it uh it sends
Telemetry data for HTTP request for uh
web app I enable aspen.net core
instrument installation it's different
type of instrumentation which I enabled
but as you see they uh
the traces that built from this data uh
so it goes to web server and so on and
here are my tags so what again as I
mentioned before it's just a couple of
headers which
makes it possible to to to correlate
this data what kind of headers we will
see by looking at rabbitmq
uh because what I did I stopped Q
consumer and I'm running uh from dock
container rabbitmq on my Mac so what
happens now my web application is
actually sending every uh word we should
read from the database to the rabbit so
actually what I can do I can expect
uh
this queue and I can get messages
let's get let's get a message
yeah and that's uh
you can see that the actual payload is
quite
small
okay do I have it
[Music]
um
yeah so this is over this is a word but
there are a couple of headers which are
sent
to the rabbit in queue here there is a
trace parent and there is a correlation
ID so that's sufficient actually to
build open uh telemetic races so when we
collect these messages from the queue by
running Q consumer it will recreate open
Telemetry distributed context it will
propagate it and will continue so what
we're going to do now
is that we will start this open
Telemetry queue consumer
run Q consumer
yeah I think now we probably will see
that there are no messages queue
messages
interesting oh yeah now it's zero
and if we go back to
Jager actually I don't know how to
pronounce the next Jager or Jagger any
any tips
because I'm sort of yeah because I
broken Norway and then in Norwich it's
Jagger Jager okay uh yeah so
search
uh web app find traces you see uh we uh
we didn't send more messages new new
messages but our traces which only had
two segments uh two Services now they
have extra segment and there is queue
consumer so if I open this Trace
there is a queue consumer here and then
you see that it it uh it happened
somewhere there because uh I was talking
describing things and then and then so
now the original uh
Trace segments there are somewhere here
and then this came after a few minutes
so basically as long as you have data in
your back end as long as they are not
deleted uh if if you have a message
somewhere and service bus and a queue
and then you collect this message in one
year your distributed Trace will be in
reach will be extended so this is also
powerful thing and then uh so your uh
distribute it's very easy to build
simple Trace traces and you just need to
agree with uh uh the whole organization
with all the teams what backend you use
and make sure that uh data stays long
enough to build interesting traces but
most of the traces of course say they're
built using you know some seconds
minutes in our organization it can be
ours because we deal with media files
what we do is uh we upload uh metaphors
can be like tens of gigabytes and
if they're stuck in transcoding uh if
they're not
sent further for further processing it
may come with some delay and this is
interesting uh to uh explore and this is
one of the reasons we started working
with open telemetry
uh but how do we achieve that okay we
have rabbitmq which is not supported
natively by uh open Telemetry so what
does it take to make it open Telemetry
ready we have we need to do two things
first uh we go to uh
my message sender let me find it yeah
message publisher
mq publish
yeah uh when uh
when I publish a message I need to use
uh call propagator inject I need to uh
uh let open Telemetry know that okay
this is a use uh distributed contact
contract propagator and inject some
additional data so what I passed there I
need to pass some uh callbacks there
and my uh
yeah inject Trace contacts this is a
callback which will be called by a
propagator typically it's a it's a key
value so it's a dictionary of things so
I use uh what what I use here message
properties header so it's rabbit headers
what I do in this callback when uh
distributed quality propagator will call
me uh and said Okay I want to uh extend
my distributor trace or your distributed
Trace with some additional data it will
use a rabbit message headers as a
transport to to send them further to the
consumer uh because I need to uh and
this this is what we saw in this rapidmq
headers so they are injected here
and in my Q consumer
I need to do the opposite thing
no it's message Handler it's that one
activity Source propagated yeah I have
Trace context propagator and then
when I execute it
when this happens extract Trace context
uh so basically does the opposite thing
uh here are rabbitmq headers try get try
extract these values and there are two
values it's a parent ID it's a
correlation ID and then it builds the
context and uh it continues if it can't
uh extract it it will create a root uh
distributed Trace starting a root
segment for distributed Trace so the new
distributed Trace will start there
foreign
so uh let me go back to play from
current slide
yeah so that was about how you start
with uh open Telemetry uh
a few words about uh
what we do in our project
um I mentioned that we use the actor
model we use akka.net and uh with akka
there is a protocol you need to enrich
a neighbor team using and service bus
for answer service bus Jimmy Bogart who
is here in this conference he wrote
a nougat package that uh it is open
source it's free that you can use to
extend
and service bus and communication with
open Telemetry with akka it's a
commercial Library uh it's called Phobos
it supports both metrics and traces and
as I mentioned uh in the in the middle
of the talk that we first uh used this
default uh way of creating traces for
for actors and then you see that here
this Massachusetts messages it messages
so this is typical how how work with
actors like active style messages and
new message new message new message and
that's that was
not something which was easy to work
because of granularity like you have
1500 messages for uh for your business
level transaction so uh we work with
aqua team and then I came with a
uh uh a new version of forbus library
was just released version 2.1 where uh
these are uh much uh larger business
units so this is uh basically uploading
a single file each TV program consists
of five or six uh major files so we here
goes uploading and we control it
ourselves so this is uploading files and
these are messages events that we get
from uh from the origin which uh receive
this file so for every like business
level transaction we have something like
maybe like 2030 such uh segments in in a
transaction and then we can ourselves
decide what we need for example we can
cut down on this uh events if we only
need to uh investigate a time of upload
files so uh uh it's a
uh now we can we are in the process of
inviting other teams to to join forces
so we want to build uh transactions that
include other services uh but as I
mentioned that with if you use message
uh messaging libraries you may uh
experience that situation that your
automatic segment creation will be to
give you two two small two short
segments for you for you
so uh
to uh I'm I'm coming to conclusion of my
talk and then what I would like you to
bring
the takeout from the talk rethink your
logging strategy first of all uh this is
uh how we started going towards open
Telemetry uh I learning too much we'll
we've been logging uh
sometimes tens of millions uh log
entries a day and that's you know that's
too much to to explore and uh 99 of it
just just waste because when things uh
uh going fine that you you don't mean
them uh
can small amount of traces replace huge
number of logs so yes traces are much
more informative because they give you
context and especially if uh you have
distributed traces then you have a
single
source of uh information when you need
to investigate what happens
to your business transactions
so find a suitable opportunity backend
dashboard and what we found out that
it's not just uh
qualities of like how nicely dashboard
looks running costs are very important
because uh some back-end some providers
can be very expensive and they give you
much more than just open Telemetry so
you need to find what
costs are sufficient for you also uh
part of that is doing your application
performance monitoring you can get a lot
of that from your back from your backend
for events which you select but there
quite different quite opinionated the
way they build application performance
so use some time and let's see gate
whether or not it will
fit you
so I think we still have uh time for
some questions
um
yeah if you have any questions
objections observations please shoot out
10 question for me
uh are you interested in do you think
that there is a place for in your
projects to uh to try open Telemetry and
if you don't like why can anyone
who thinks that there is a place for
petalum to try
majority who is not sort of convinced
and think that there are some you know
there are some struggles with that
okay that sounds uh promising
uh okay
so uh then please enjoy the rest of the
conference and I'm still here so if you
have any uh other questions like private
questions about your projects then I'm
available thank you very much
foreign